well wishers gathered to light candles
outside of the hospital where NFL player
Demar Hamlin remains in critical
condition after last night's game in
Cincinnati officials say the 24-year-old
Buffalo Bills player suffered Cardiac
Arrest shortly after tackling a player
on the opposing team the bills later
confirmed his heartbeat was restored on
the field after CPR was performed for
several minutes the game was suspended
indefinitely after the incident many
fellow NFL players and athletes from
other sports quickly offered their
support and prayers on social media
life's more important than a game and
people are more important in the game
than I just had I hope I hope he's okay
I know his mama's here and Buffalo's
friend for him and
whatever you believe in like Good Vibes
and passive energy towards them and like
hopefully he's okay well I I saw the hit
later I saw the uh the site from I think
it was probably Monday Night Football
where he stood up and dropped down
um everything got dead silent um
even the Bengals fans you know you don't
want to see anything like that certainly
praying for Hamlin's family you know
Demar a great person you know
great football player so we're just
bringing that everything's okay we've
heard some bad rumors they're just
rumors but uh yeah it's devastating do
you think your presence here tonight
and I see Bengals fans but also Bills
fans well this signifies Unity that's
what it signifies to signifies that
we're all human and that's what comes
first nothing else just get
the Gathering and the concern
and just wanting to do something I think
that's why most people are here you know
you feel like you need to do something
and so this is a way of just
showing that you care
and definitely prayers for us mom I hope
she's not there by herself
that she has someone there I know she
had to go in the ambulance with anybody
just praying for I I saw that what it
was how I was in the air I saw it was
bad the whole team was on the field
I ain't never seen it like that but like
a lot of people were nervous we all
realized that we ain't never seen
nothing like that in our life like
because it was about 45 minute wait
and it's just I I knew it was it was
going downhill and I I didn't like it
I'm glad the game got called that would
have been the most awkward game ever
been played amen I mean yeah they need
to care more about the player's ages
they say they care they care about
players but they're really mean okay
they showed that they care about it but
it's just like why does that happen why
does that happen it's a big thing but
the game should go on we're really
really praying for damir Hamlin we hope
he's okay and go bills go Bengals